[Music]
i can't wait to see what you've been
thinking about now
i know i just i thought i'd you know we
touched on this in another
explainer video it has to do with
uh you you gave me the term you know i
as an educator if i'm teaching somebody
something i'm not going to give them all
details all at once
because that could be distracting you
want to work your way in step by step
right so there's certain there's certain
rounds of information
that you bring in once a person has
mastered the previous information
basically like you're on a need-to-know
basis that's what you called it
and i didn't wanna i didn't wanna agree
with that fact but like that kind of
what it is
isn't it it's well it is yeah it's just
like well why does that happen no
that i'll never forget i had a calculus
tutor my first year calculus
chuck you needed a tutor i'm very decent
i did i needed a calculus tutor
uh and we went we went to the we got to
a certain place
and this is why i needed a tutor and he
told me this is why i needed a tutor
we would get to a certain point in the
equation and i would say
but why is that he would go bro
that's calculus three just relax
this is how it works and chill your
armpits
right and i couldn't accept that i was
like no
you gotta explain to me why that and
he was like it worked so you were ready
for the next round i don't know if i was
ready for the next round i just wanted
to understand why that
that you couldn't and but anyway okay so
we don't know whether had he explained
the next rounds you would have given up
calculus entirely
and so that whether he was right exactly
or
whether you were ready for the next
round and they were holding you back
we don't know you know what i mean you
know i'd like to think the latter
but it could be the former would it be
funny if he actually gave me like
the most detailed explanation from
calculus 3
as to why this is happening and i was
just like
all right that's it i quit
we first hit this when we asked the
question what
um what is the path of earth's orbit
around the sun
okay now if like i said if you don't
know anything about orbits or planets or
solar systems
you're just brand new you walked out of
a cave you've been there your whole life
i will say earth's orbit around the sun
is a circle
okay and because it's easy to think
about a circle you can draw it you can
wasn't it drawn that way anyway at one
point oh it was
uh planetary orbits were circles through
and including copernicus yeah yeah they
didn't become not circles until
after copernicus copernicus famous work
that put the sun back in the middle of
the solar system
all those orbits were perfect circles
now you know you're learning man
that if someone says earth's orbit is a
circle you're going to say no
you're going to tell me it's an ellipse
a slightly flattened circle right
okay uh let me tell you that earth is
like a three percent
ellipse okay so if i drew it
and then i if i drew a three percent
ellipse and then i drew a more elongated
ellipse and i said which one
best uh approximates earth's orbit
you're probably going to
point to the more elongated one because
you heard that it's an ellipse
also that's that that's the visuals that
you were
presented with when you look or exactly
but but i'm just saying when you
but a three percent ellipse if you draw
it and you at a glance it looks like a
perfect circle
okay so so but you're right but they
actually
but wait let me just back this up for
one second for my own
comfort the actual orbit is
indeed a three percent ellipse is that
what you're saying correct
oh yes okay well that changes everything
because that looks like a circle
it looks like a circle if if you're only
three percent different in one direction
than the other direction right
are you even going to notice that not
really that's my point yes actually that
so i can draw that and draw a more
elongated one almost everybody's going
to point to the elongated
yeah we know it's showing off that they
know that we're an ellipse right
and they'll be wrong in so doing okay so
by the way right now i just found out
that earth's orbit
is a three percent ellipse
i did not know that yes so at our
closest we are like 91 million miles
from the sun right and at our farthest
about 94 94 million wow yeah that is
that is very little
wireless 94. movement that's not only
that's three percent on a hundred
three hundred wow yeah otherwise
the sun would get really big in one
season and really small in the i mean
you don't see that
no you don't right okay so now you come
out of the cave and you say okay i got
it it's a circle
okay we uh is there more i said yes it's
not actually a circle
okay it moves a little closer to the sun
and a little farther away we have a word
for that it's called an ellipse
and we can watch that happen okay so at
this time of year
measure the size of the sun on the sky
i'll give them a little tool to do that
and wait six months later and you find
out it's smaller
all right so we are closest to the sun
in january
and farthest from the sun in july okay
and january is called perihelion and
july is called aphelion
there you go all right and people say
well wait a minute if we're closest to
the sun in january how come it's colder
what all that means is a temperature on
earth has nothing to do with how far
away we are from the sun
okay let me guess i'm taking a guess
here
so because the earth sits on a tilt of
23 degrees
it's not about how close we are
it's about where the sun is hitting us
on that
that tilt correct and so if you're
tilted towards the sun the rays are much
more direct
wait a minute did you just say correct
yes i did
that's exactly correct get out
so watch so if you tilt towards the sun
um
as we are in january then i mean uh
sorry uh
we are in july then the ground heating
is much more significant
and that's that's what takes us into
summer meanwhile the folks in the
southern hemisphere
are tilted away away that's why they get
winter
when we get summer and then it switches
i was really guessing okay
very good guest i thought you were going
to say well that makes a lot of sense
chuck
but yeah that makes sense in your head
right
okay so now that now they're all good
with the ellipse and i say all the
planets are in ellipses
all right some are less so than others
pluto is particularly elliptical in the
long list of weird things about it
and venus is particularly
circular but everybody is some form of
an ellipse
okay so now we're good there and that's
how that's where most people are that's
where most people have been left
absolutely but there's more okay
all right if i act now will i also
receive
but wait so now what so
uh earth and the moon
orbit each other okay okay so we're not
just sitting in one place with moon
going around us
the moon and earth each orbit their
common center of mass
okay okay now obviously the center of
mass is going to be much closer to earth
because earth
has more mass and this is even if it
sounds a little weird it's completely
intuitive if you walk up to a barbell
and they're more weights on one side
than the other and i asked where would
you have to pick it up
so that you balanced it you don't want
to pick it up closer to the heavy side
closer to the heavy side and then you
can get a balance point on that
that's true for anything you pick up
right if you want to find the balance
point
so what that means is earth's path
around the sun
is not a circle it's not an ellipse
it's a loop-de-loop oh because it's
doing the little merry-go-round
it's with the moon it's doing the moon
it's doing it it's doing the moon jiggle
right okay that's that center of mass is
a thousand miles
beneath earth's surface in a line
connecting the center of the earth to
the center of the
moon so the earth is not doing this
it's not doing this it's like doing this
right the center mass is inside its own
yeah it's like
it's like a it's like a black girl
telling you off
let me tell you you stuck listen to me
you better listen to me when i uh you
all know
me you don't know me
yes exactly like that chuck okay so yes
it's basically a circle
it's also basically an ellipse but on
top of that ellipse are these
loop-de-loops
right okay and not only that
okay the path that earth takes around
the sun
does not rejoin itself in the same spot
so in other words it's not a closed
orbit
no all right so the point for so for
example the point where we are closest
to the sun
that actually shifts every single year
and migrates around the sun
it's called the procession oh that is
so so cool it's a so it's a whole other
level so now i'll teach you about
procession
and i teach about how that works and the
gravity torquing because
we're not a perfect sphere where a mass
is unequally distributed
wait a minute gravity twerks a
[Laughter]
so sorry man that would be cool
it wouldn't be cool no no if the moon
mooned us with a twerk the moon is
twerking up
actually there's something called
libration on the moon right
where sometimes the moon's orbit it's a
head of where
would be on average and sometimes it's
behind of where it is on average
so you can see a little bit around on
the other side
right okay so if you look at sort of
static
camera shot video shots of the moon
librating okay this is us looking but
it's so the moon is actually doing this
right it's the moon it's kind of it's
doing a back and forth
so maybe you can call that twerking
vibration is moon twerking moon twerk
nice all right so this is an example of
if you want more and more detail you
have to keep going
right and it's a matter of what level of
educational instruction
is in progress that's wrong though that
they don't
come on everybody learns about orbits
and you learn about it
pretty much middle school high school
right yeah for that first earth science
or something
science thank you and that's when you
start taking them
knowing about procession that is so cool
yeah and i did not know this that is
that is just
a really you'd have a perception even
without the loop-de-loops
right so all of these are happening like
all at once
and so so the real truth is
deeper and more complex and more
interesting than typically whatever
is taught on the first round that's all
i'm saying and that is true for
almost everything that's taught right
so you can i'll give you one more
example okay we gotta land this plane
so if you ask me how wide is the sun
that's okay yeah how wide is the sun uh
on this
it's 864 000 miles across
okay okay uh you know not quite a
million miles across
all right all right and that's fine and
if you look it up in a book it'll give
you that number
but wait a minute um
the sun is a ball of gas right so
where is the edge how are you
doing the edge of that what it how
is that what so well you say okay well
we
you know you take a picture and you put
a thing okay well whose edge is that
that edge that you see is the last
point of light that had scattered on its
way to the edge and then escaped the sun
but that's visible light right okay
other wavelengths of light
emanate from the sun at different depths
so if you took an x-ray picture of the
sun you'll get a
different dimension for how big the sun
is than if you take an
ultraviolet or an infrared
so so when you just say how big is the
sun
you can get an answer that satisfies
most needs
but if you really want to know what's
going on you have to get into the weeds
right you've got to dig in and then say
how are you defining it and how does
that vary
and how big is that difference and there
are some stars that actually
pulsate and to say how big is the star
you have to say well i asked when asked
me
when where in its cycle do you want to
know how big it is
right most variable stars in the night
sky
that start this category star called
variable because they get brighter and
dimmer over
on a schedule right they get bigger and
smaller
so some questions don't just have simple
answers
but but not every educator is going to
tell you that at every point
right so now i have to ask this because
you talk about variable stars
and you know we sit in a nursery rhyme
twinkle twinkle little star
we also look up at times and we see
stars twinkling
do we have time for you to explain why
exactly do stars twinkle
not in this explainer
we got it we can put that in another one
all right you know i can't put the whole
world in the universe
in 10 minutes here i don't know what you
what what you know what do you what do
you want from me
i i'm only one scientist am i just gym i
can't
do it i can't do everything
so the point is um ideas matter more
than
any of these details right and so yeah
it's an important idea that the
sun goes earth goes around the sun and
the rest are details that's fine and
that idea gets you to other ideas and
so but without joking let me just say
this
what is so critically important about
what you are saying
is that when we look at the scientific
method and we look at science
itself um what it does is
allows you to open your mind to the
possibilities
of change and the rigid thinking that
most people
adopt and say it is either this or that
or who or they think scientists have
rigid thinking right
because that leads to people saying
things like i don't want to wear a mask
because
quite frankly the science is junk
and the reason they say it is because
things have
changed we know more so we change
the way we present information based
upon an
increase in knowledge or an availability
of more
information correct and so
so that's all correct
but an important difference in most
cases there are very
counter examples of this but in most
cases the extra information
is an improvement on what you previously
knew
right it doesn't completely throw away
what was previously
learned or understood or researched so
that's why i said with the orbit around
the sun
each next thing is a nuance on the
previous one right
right when i say this the earth is doing
loop-de-loops you don't have to abandon
the idea that it's an ellipse
because the the loops are on an ellipse
right and so
so you can keep the and keep the nested
infrared like the nested russian dolls
there's more detail and and you can stop
where you want and you're good with that
sweet you got it right all right chuck
we gotta we gotta land that plane
okay well next time we get to know why
stars twinkle
yes
all right chuck always good to have you
always good to be here neil degrasse
tyson
signing off of course bitty keep looking